okay so we're here for the episode we're
going to the Kern River travels in such
tube in addition with Cornell Reed and
Billy windings
[Music]
well we're cruising through Bakersfield
and Billy is just like there any weight
stores around here so now we gotta go
get weed for this addict that's not a
weed store I mean I'm sure you could buy
weed yeah well couldn't you buy we are
around Bakersfield to come in just a
weed stores bigger this is that's so far
it's not the one that they said it was
we got to get in and out before we go
there
[Music]
awesome thank you all right there's a
YouTube button
okay those are food you can see the one
for Billy right there and then the other
two healthy burgers are now hookers
yeah edge deals on them so I turned left
here yeah right in and out to the weed
store classic camping situation this is
to get beat which is legal and I'm sure
you had a pot shop buy your home yes you
can take them
they've got lobbies turn left in Howard
Avenue how far away is that I don't know
Bakersfield that well we have been
driving around Bakersfield
way too long let's eat is this
laughs left here on Chester yeah
you didn't say Chester before he said
Norris there's mirrors I don't know
[Music]
so it explained what happened in there
and the Bakersfield okay marijuana shop
there was first of all there's no
signage that tells you what it is you
know there's no a green cross there's no
hey this is the weed store just like an
empty room and then there's a curtain
behind like one of those windows and the
guy took my ID for a long time and then
was like I go in and I went to the ATM
which is a $4 they just had jars of
adequate weed and I was like do you guys
have pre rows or anything he's like
usually
[Music]
I was at my friend's house and we had
one Riley we're like calling up girls
you know yeah like me so pressure my
friend to call up this girl and be like
you know I want to like tell I want to
kiss you or whatever ha ha
he calls no one picks up the phone it
goes to the answering machine and my
friend I don't know what he's thinking
he goes is message is for Jamie you
can't have her call me back because I
really really want to [ __ ] her something
yeah we're gonna float
we did pick we're cutting it close to
acceptable get in the water days
[Music]
okay I'm Brooks Cornell Billy Wayne
we're camping on the Kern for this
episode we set up a tent Billy goes over
there and it's nice Holliman Cornell and
I we got pretty close to set it up but
we feel like our body's gonna keep us
down keep it keep it weighted down for
living yeah I never gets windy at night
a lot of people like to glamp I like our
camp being set up to look like we didn't
know we were gonna go camping today
yeah we're blam pin never hung this up
before your feet had to be so well just
land on this barren Corona I found yeah
that's a spot you know well it's like a
berry trigger I got there
not drunk this is
no the good pop oh no I don't think so
it'll get you drunk
just be careful I can't drink it out of
this I'll pour it in a cup
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's the plan my plan oh boy we
getting punch in the mouth and I'm gonna
make out it smells like your dad's beer
I love it you don't have refined palate
I can see that we did it we did what
we're supposed to do I don't think he
did what
[Laughter]
keep your legs out try to keep your legs
out so comfy feel like jimmy buffett's
feel secure margarita you look like the
letter j this is how this is called
living if i walked up on you
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so it's a balmy 65 almost perfectly
so time to go to three very fit men to
uh tube in what was made for pools
I mean rapid right or dude yeah but
doesn't know how the Kern rolls we
shouldn't be we shouldn't feel great
together
I also going to say stay vigilant like
don't it say okay down this way
let's go cool down that worked up the
big sweat this is the Kern River named
after Colonel Sanders just go yeah yeah
gets mad if you don't call it the
colonel
it makes great chicken well that's a
great way to start all right it was a
dunk
you don't want to get here
[Laughter]
you just pee right here you could oh
yeah we could stay in the 15 degrees
difference like I stopped shaking when
the Sun comes
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
I want to get out of this water these
Hot Springs aren't Julie all right now
take it there we found the way to go to
jump and it's deep enough let it sit
[Music]
what does known in Iowa to squirrel
one of theirs way too hot
I feel a sort of privada disgust talking
with authority in persons believe in him
but you just trust everything that guy
says I'm going straight to the DA I have
no idea what I'm doing talking [ __ ] on
him you may believe that maybe this guy
is on a lazy river yeah these cups of
hot cocoa so we floated down the Kern
River we fell in love we found these
great Hot Springs I think we could call
it a success really I see success a
success
yeah
it's really fun actually it was really
good
I enjoy the heck out of somebody one
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay we had a nice day too big to open
up rocks and hot springs and I'm a
girlfriend's hat in the car and now we
are
skipped around
almost all the way across the river
I think we got a winner
this is a good-ass profit
[Music]
got some steaks I think I have like
stuff to put them in all right let's
keep this guy on here and then we go
let's put some more butter on that then
we'll clean with you know not much use
my breakup knife he's over some slow
cookers that clock and no sizzle okay
okay no it doesn't make sense I know
what I'm doing smoke Falls Beauty man
there we go all right drop that guy down
and then uh the 40 minutes maybe flip
them oh oh yeah we just over the trash
[Laughter]
shotgun three beers and eat hummus with
your finger the crew brought lobsters so
we're his way to put what he's done
ruined some lobster - why don't we
really turn this yeah we're serving
turkey yeah these cows for you got mr.
river health of his lobster tail
actually did bring Zoe Carter I just
give my poetry bag right a bunch of
condoms on this condom is safe okay I
don't dress the sleeping bag I think
that's as long as I've ever made it in
this show without being like hammering
so that's the thing growing up we
haven't grown up a little bit and we got
to watch it together catch us
nice
we're that that's good
this is exactly 100% the same as naked
and afraid
how was it
I think it's good good I've never a beat
on it yeah I'm with yep I think I liked
it though yeah I think our steaks are
done now we get to eat these that's hot
here we go very hot through the hot
springs all over again
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm just trying to get a little bit of
Kinlan I learned this from Johnny
Pemberton and probably go to bed after
this we had steaks that were good yeah
gonna get some kindling before bed
you're gonna sleep down right the three
of us need to put this on the fire
together and that's how we say good good
night and we'll see you tomorrow morning
okay good night good night we'll see you
tomorrow morning and we're going to put
the fire out now one two three bye do it
up hearing this you fix that in post
ouch mix that post success I like look
we gotta step we're not let's stop doing
this for the show I just kidding we'll
play with the fire for a little bit
before we go to bed actually
[Music]
[Applause]
a car to a balmy
twenty-eight degrees Fahrenheit it's a
little chilly
now I slept in my tent with Cornell
really wedged in next to me that was
nice and told me he could get on the air
mattress that I brought but it was a
no-go yeah so I shared the tent with
Brooks again I did that last episode and
he had a double air mattress so we both
weren't comfortable just laughing about
how snug that air mattress was and how
much space we have and how wonderful it
was and I guess that popped or something
this time Brooks brought a single air
mattress in a tent fairly big enough for
two so a singles real nights to cover up
about one and a half person it deflated
in the middle of the night anyway and
then I slept on rocks way to go to dam
would do this some parts are low get our
ass
let you know you're alive then you
jumped up for robbed twice
and then we found hot springs I'm not
gonna tell you where there
I never [ __ ] like Brooks Billy's
always rubbed me the wrong way but
somehow I made it through I don't know
is a pretty [ __ ] awesome day
I would encourage anyone to come to
where we did but we're not
we should've slept in this hammock
contrary to what those Liars said this
is perfect this is how you're supposed
to do it it's wonderful I'm sipping my
Joe I got plenty around I could do
whatever I want over here oh the only
time I was afraid for my life is when we
went in when I went into that dispensary
in victory that was it that was the only
time where I was like this is sketchy as
hell I was a little afraid for my life
after drinking that 1980s Corona we dug
up from the dirt I feel like I've had
the sniffles ever since now that I'm
thinking about it maybe I wasn't
shivering at all it was just convulsions
the whole day I'm true to a 30-year old
Corona a man challenged me to stay in
the hot water as long as I could
it was purely a funny game to him I only
brought one pair of shoes and they
didn't dry out
brought three pairs of socks had to pee
around 1:30 in the morning and I just
somehow absorbed it back into my body as
opposed to getting out of my tent
because it was so cold
help help my pee for about six hours and
just looked up if they need the darkness
my legs hurt in this situation so I'm
gonna get out of this and I'm gonna go
home because it's a Wednesday and I have
to I have to go do stuff that isn't a
free internet TV show okay thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you